alors malgré sa non présence plus
sérieusement c'est cette absence halo 3
2018 qui m'a donné envie de faire cette
vidéo alors du coup que savons-nous sur
ce final fantasy 7 remake eh bien c'est
ce que nous allons voir dans cette vidéo
tout
[Musique]
alors tout d'abord il semblerait que la
malédiction côté final fantasy chez
square enix est toujours d'actualité
puisqu'il est à noter que le
développement de final fantasy 7 remake
et eu pas mal de complications un petit
peu comme ff 15 oui le jeu a été annoncé
à l'e3 2015 et un second trailer quant à
lui plus tourné vers le gameplay sortie
fin d'année 2015 cependant après plus
rien silence radio
cela fait aujourd'hui quatre ans que
final fantasy 7 remake est en
développement puisqu'il a débuté en 2014
alors oui le développement a commencé il
ya quatre ans mais malheureusement le
jeu n'a subi que deux ans de
développement pour le moment c'est cette
période où justement square enix nous a
sorti ses deux trailer étant plutôt pas
mal productif en fait pour vous
expliquer le jeu était pas mal développé
par cyberconnect2 en terme de gameplay
puisque c'est une entreprise qui est
plus situés dans les jeux de combat sont
développées par exemple les naruto ninja
ultimate et du coup ce sont deux qui
sont chargés du gameplay de final
fantasy 7 remake mais ce fut
malheureusement un échec pour square
enix qui durent prendre le développement
et le jeu à cyberconnect2 qui n'avançait
pas du tout et qui du coup retarde
lourdement la sortie de ce ff 7
c'est d'ailleurs suite à ce problème que
nous avons pu voir des annonces de
yoshinori kitase et et naoki hamaguchi
cherchant un développeur pour justement
final fantasy 7
alors oui ça fait pas mal amateurs mais
il n'avait pas vraiment de choix à ce
moment là
alors pourquoi est-ce aussi l'ont déjà
par rapport aux problèmes suite au
développement du jeu mais surtout car
tetsuya nomura à celui qui dirige toute
l'opération depuis plusieurs effets fnh
ne veux pas faire un simple relooking de
ff7 et donc pas qu'un simple remake
le jeu sera totalement revisité et mis
au goût du jour je pense que vous n'avez
pas besoin de moi pour voir justement
les deux trailer voir le changement qui
est apportée final fantasy c'était long
et conséquent cela prend du temps
et justement ce sera un pari très risqué
puisque square enix a décidé de proposer
final fantasy 7 remake de façon
épisodique gros et volumineux sont deux
mots qui caractérisent très bien final
fantasy 7 remake et qui du coup
expliquerait pourquoi le choix de ce
format après je vous cache pas que dans
l'ère moderne du jeu vidéo dans laquelle
nous sommes
le fait de proposer un jeu multi cd rom
est quand même un gros risque parce
qu'on est vraiment plus habite fait on
est plus fin années 90 d'ailleurs ce
choix de faire de façon épisodique
pourrait se justifier aussi à cause du
temps étant donné que le jeu est long et
prend beaucoup de temps à se développer
du coup à sortir histoire de ne pas
faire trop attendre les fans
peut-être que le jeu sera proposé de
façon épisodique justement pour ne pas
faire trop attendre ses fans cela reste
surtout à cause du volume du jeu comme
alors je ne vais pas précisé auparavant
mais bien évidemment l'équipe de final
fantasy 7 remake et
érigée par tetsuya nomura un nom célèbre
dans la saga de final fantasy puisqu'il
a été présent sur bon nombre de ces
derniers et fut celui qui dirigea la
reprise du développement de final
fantasy 15 le jeu est aussi dirigée par
yoshinori kitase et le directeur
scénaristique du jeu accompagné de naoki
hamaguchi qui l'épaulent kazushige
nojima un scénariste yusuke naora le
directeur artistique sans oublier notre
dieu à tous
nobuo uematsu à la musique
ce dernier avait justement quitté square
enix mais a finalement accepté de faire
les musiques de ce ff 7 remake
il est d'ailleurs le créateur des
musiques d'origine plus le temps passe
plus les final fantasy évoluent et
deviennent conséquent final fantasy 15
apporte un nouveau vent de fraîcheur et
un tournant risquer à la saga puisque si
ce dernier ne se vendait pas bien la
saga final fantasy se serait
prématurément arrêté au final fantasy 7
remake sera je pense un très bon jeu il
restera bien évidemment fidèle à
l'histoire d'origine ainsi qu'au monde
instauré par ff7 oublié par contre le
tour par tour où la jauge atb puisque
depuis f-15 les gros final fantasy qui
lui succéderont posséderont le même
gameplay en fait quelque chose de bien
nerveux et bien dynamique
le jeu sera également doublée chaque
personnage possédera sa propre voie et
je pense qu une vf ne sera pas négligé
espérant qu'elle soit aussi bonne que
celle de ff 15 par contre enfin quelle
serait la date définitive de la sortie
de ff et bien
désolé mais ça sera pas avant 2023 cela
a été affirmé dans une interview
en gros ils espèrent avoir lancé le jeu
avant les 35 ans de la saga mais bon
rien n'est trop précise et donc les
suppositions reste encore grande
est-ce que 2023 symbolise l'arrivée du
premier épisode de ff7 remake ou
symbolise justement l'arrivée du dernier
épisode de ff7 remake est que pour 2023
tout est sorti tout est clôturée ceci
reste encore un gros mystère et fait 15
de part son histoire et son
développement a grandement perturbé
l'entreprise de square enix qui changea
totalement de points de vue et de façon
de travailler sur ces jeux oui c'est
long oui c'est chiant mais au moins et
je l'espère la qualité sera normalement
au rendez vous final fantasy et ma saga
culte depuis mon adolescence et je suis
très curieux de voir ce qui nous
proposons alors sachez que je serai au
rendez vous et j'espère que ma petite
vidéo vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleus c'est
important à vous abonner à cette chaîne
si vous désirez suivre mon contenu à me
suivre sur twitter et puis que le 'lion'
alors soit avec vous cet état regorge
allez ciao
[Musique]